[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian
sieers guten Abend in allen money makes
the world go round gilt auch für die
Welt der Parteien Geld gibt die
Möglichkeit Positionen und Vorhaben in
die Öffentlichkeit zu tragen für sich zu
werben ohne Geld keine Wahlkampagne für
die rechtsextreme NPD die sich
mittlerweile die Heimat nennt ist jetzt
allerdings der letzte Rest staatlicher
Hilfe weggebrochen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat heute
einstimmig entschieden keine staatliche
Parteienfinanzierung mehr für eine
Partei die diesen Staat und seine
freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung
bekämpfen und beseitigen will so klar
der Richterspruch aus Karlsruhe so
unterschiedlich die Antworten auf die
Frage was er für andere Parteien
bedeuten könnte bei der AFD etwa kamen
202 etwa 44% ihrer gesamten Einnahmen
vom stat SAR te und Samuel Kirsch mit
mehr sie wollen es wissen Schülerinnen
und Schüler der Waldorfschule pzeim aus
BadenWürttemberg sind heute zum
Bundesverfassungsgericht gereist um die
Entscheidung GLE
mitzuerleben wir haben auch gerade
geschichtepoche den Zweiten Weltkrieg
und weiß du die Politik die erinnert
mich auch immer an was jetzt gerade
passiert und wir wollen natürlich nicht
dass es wieder passiert oder sich
wiederholt einfach auch vielleicht eine
Grenze zu setzen wie viel rechts in der
Partei sein darf ich glaube wichtig ist
zu gucken ob so eine Partei die ziemlich
rechts ist und ziemlich extrem ist ob
die noch unterstützt wird von dem Staat
wird sie nicht mehr erfahren die
Schülerinnen und Schüler im Saal der NPD
wird alle staatliche Finanzierung für
JRE gestrichen der Grund die
Antragsgegnerin missachtet nach wie vor
die freiheitliche demokratische
Grundordnung und ist nach ihren Zielen
und dem Verhalten ihrer Mitglieder und
Anhänger auf deren Beseitigung
ausgerichtet die Antragsgegnerin die
exnpd die sich jetzt Heimat nennt
boyottiert die Urteilsverkündung äußert
sich später per Pressemitteilung trotz
sich wer glaut das würde uns aus dem
Spiel werfen und uns aufhalten der
täuscht sich gewaltig mit heute wird zum
ersten Mal in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik einer Partei die
staatliche Finanzierung gestrichen denn
das Verfassungsgericht stellt fest dass
sich die NPD gegen die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung richtet
konkret gegen die Demokratie und die
Menschenwürde sowohl das Konzept der
ethnisch definierten Volksgemeinschaft
als auch die antisemitische Grundhaltung
und die verächtlichmung der bestehenden
demokratischen Ordnung lassen deutliche
Parallelen zum Nationalsozialismus
erkennen bundesinnenministerin Feser
sieht in dem Urteil ein klares Signal
das über den Tag
hinausreicher unser demokratischer
Rechtsstaat finanziert keine
Verfassungsfeinde und auch wenn die
verfassungsrechtlichen Hürden für
künftige Verfahren hoch bleiben haben
wir jetzt ein weiteres Instrument um
gegen Verfassungsfeinde vorzugehen aus
der AFD gibt es heute auch auf Nachfrage
kein Statement zum npdurteil aus der
Union kommen gemischte Signale für
Markus Söder ist das Urteil wegweisend
man müsse dasselbe nun auch für die AFD
prüfen aber wenn das Verfassungsgericht
uns jetzt die Möglichkeit gibt unterhalb
der Schwelle des offiziellen
Verbotsverfahrens eine Möglichkeit zu
setzen Grenzen zu ziehen die
Verfassungsfeinde in ihrem agieren
einzuschränken dann sollte man alles
prüfen ob das nicht geht und machbar ist
und meint damit die AFD denn die erhielt
zuletzt mehr als 10 Millionen an
staatlicher
Finanzierung
wir ja wir merken also da wird in der
Politik diskutiert was das heißt für ein
mögliches Vorgehen gegen die
AFD Sarah Tacke ist hier bei uns unsere
Rechtsexpertin guten Abend Sarah was
haben denn die Richterin und Richter aus
Karlsruhe da heute für Fingerzeige
gegeben sie haben deutlich gemacht dass
es zwei scharfe Schwerter gegen
verfassungsfeindlich Parteien gibt das
ein ist Parteiverbot über das wurde
schon viel diskutiert und das andere
wurde heute wenn man so will scharf
gestellt zum erst mal angewendet das ist
der Ausschluss von der staatlichen
Finanzierung für verfassungsfeindlich
Parteien das ist ein relativ junger
Artikel im Grundgesetz der auch extra
reingehoben wurde um vorzugehen und da
sind wir schon beim zentralen
Unterschied gegen Parteien die zwar
verfassungsfeindlich sind aber so
erfolglos so bedeutungslos wie die NPD
dass man sie gar nicht verbieten muss
den kann man Tag heute ist klar die
Finanzierung streichen bei der AFD ist
allerdings klar da gilt vieles aber
nicht dass sie bedeutungs oder erfolglos
ist und für beide Verfahren gilt und das
ist die hohe Hörde die genommen werden
muss dass eine Partei
verfassungsfeindlich sein muss und zwar
in ihrer Gesamtheit also nicht einzelne
Personen nicht ein Flügel sondern die
Partei bis in ihre frühungsetagen als
Ganzes verfassungsfeindlich und auch da
haben die Richter und Richter heute
spannende Ausführung gemacht und noch
mal deutlich gemacht dass beispielsweise
ein ethnischer Volksbegriff also ein
rassistischer Volksbegriff Deutscher ist
nur wer deutsches Blut hat nicht wer
deutschen Pass hat und wer deutsches
Blut hat muss besser gestellt werden
dass ein solcher Volksbegriff gegen
Artikel 1 Grundgesetz unsere
Menschenwürde verstößt das kann man bei
der NPD klar nachsagend das das ist klar
das ist belegt die NPD ist
verfassungsfandlich ob das bei der AFD
der Fall ist vollkommen offen das heißt
in beiden Fällen wenn man rechtlich
gegen die AFD vorgehen will muss diese
hohe Hörde ihr nachzuweisen dass sie
verfassungshintlich ist diese hohe Hörde
muss genommen werden interessante
Analyse zum Thema SAR herzlichen Dank
dafür heute
Abend ja re Migration dieses Unwort das
den Plan beschreibt massenhaft Menschen
mit migrationsh Hintergrund aus
Deutschland zu vertreiben das steht ganz
harmlos wirkend neben anderen Themen wie
Wohnungs und bildungsnot in der
Einladung heute Abend zu einem
Bürgertreff im beschaulichen Ort Eitorf
im Rhein siegkreis NRW eingeladen haben
drei Bundestagsabgeordnete der AFD die
Veranstaltung ist öffentlich sie ist
umstritten und sie hat jetzt eine
Gegendemonstration auf den Plan gerufen
Heiko
Rans kein Platz für Nazis mehrere
tausend Menschen demonstrieren am Abend
gegen die AFD für die kleine gemeind
Eitorf im rehein siegkreis ist das eine
beachtliche Anzahl die Wut bei den
Menschen ist groß einige demonstrieren
zum ersten Mal
überhaupt ich war schon immer sensibel
für diese Themen und das was jetzt heute
20 24 passiert das ist unmöglich ich
dachte das hätten wir überwunden aber
die Welt dreht sich zurück mit der AFD
möchte
einfach ja zeigen dass Deutschland Bund
ist und das wollen wir auch also ich
möchte einfach dass es so bleibt das ist
ein Trost in dieser Zeit wo vieles sehr
sehr schlecht läuft dass so viele
Menschen gesichtszeigung und Haltung
zeigen während draußen die Menschen
demonstrieren redet die AFD drinnen beim
Bürgertreff über ihre Themen allen voran
die sogenannte
Remigration die Vertreibung von Menschen
mit Migrationshintergrund
essollten das hen deswegen drängt sich
der begriffigration auch auf ob man
jetzt Rückführung nennt
Remigration oder eure Heimat braucht
euch gute Reise das meine ich gar nicht
zynisch das ist sogar
so auch Rüdiger Lukassen redet Klartext
verschwiegen wird hier
nichts W man un unterstellt dass es
vielleicht nur in einem geh heimreffen
funktioniert Lapsus kann ich nur
sagen wir werden offen darüber sprechen
diese Botschaft ist auch bei den
Demonstranten in Eitorf angekommen sind
sich die Organisatoren der Demo sicher
bin ganz sicher dass Korrektiv die
Aufdeckung die da gelaufen sind im
Moment überall ein richtiger
Beschleuniger sind dafür dass Menschen
für diese Demokratie einstehen dass sie
entsetzt sind über solche Pläne die da
geschmiedet werden im Hintergrund die
Bevölkerung hat mittlerweile erkannt
dass es nicht nur auch hle Phrasen leere
Versprechungen und auch ich sag mal Hass
ist weil da was mal mitschwingt sondern
man hat eigentlich gesehen dass es
gefährlich ist die AFD zu wählen Hamburg
München die Demonstrationen gehen weiter
nicht nur in den Metropolen sondern auch
in den kleinen Städten wie hier in
Eitorf so und weitere wichtige
Nachrichten von heute hast du jetzt im
Blick hes bei russischen Angriffen auf
mehrere Städte in der Ukraine sind in
der vergangenen Nacht nach
Behördenangaben mindestens neun Menschen
getötet und fast 80 verletzt worden
neben der Hauptstadt Kiev wurde vor
allem harkiv im Osten des Landes
getroffen alleine von dort wurden acht
Todesopfer gemeldet zahlreiche
Wohngebäude wurden beschädigt am frühen
Nachmittag gab es in mehreren Regionen
erneut
Luftalarm die Bundesregierung will die
Verteidigung der Ukraine nun auch mit
einer Lieferung von Militärhubschrauber
ausbeständen der Bundeswehr unterstützen
Minister Pistorius habe sechs
merzweckhubschrauber zugesagt teilte das
Verteidigungsministerium mit es sei die
erste deutsche Lieferung dieser Art
zuvor hatten die internationalen
Unterstützer der Ukraine im sogenannten
ramsteinformat
beraten israel lehnt im Kampf gegen die
Hamas eine Feuerpause ab solange nicht
alle Geiseln freigelassen worden sind
das hat ein Regierungssprecher erklärt
und die Kriegsziele kräftigt Zerstörung
der Regierungsfähigkeit und der
militärischen Fähigkeiten der Hamas im
Gazastreifen und die Rückkehr der
Geiseln bei den Kämpfen im Gazastreifen
sind gestern 24 israelische Soldaten
getötet worden der schwerste Verlust an
einem einzigen Tag seit Beginn des
Militäreinsatzes die von der Hamas
kontrollierte Gesundheitsbehörde meldete
gestern in den vergangenen 24 Stunden
sein 190 Palästinenser getötet
worden zwei inhaft ehemalige Abgeordnete
der Nationalkonservativen peacepartei
sind frei die beiden Männer waren vor
zwei Wochen von Polizisten im
Präsidentenpalast festgenommen worden
zuvor hat Polens Präsident duda der der
peace parartei nahe steht sie zum
zweiten Mal begnadigt der ehemalige
Innenminister Kaminski und sein enger
Mitarbeiter waren wegen Amtsmissbrauchs
verurteilt worden die peace bezeichnete
die beiden als politische
Gefangene die Bundesregierung unternimmt
einen Anlauf zum Anwerben von
Fachkräften aus Vietnam zum Auftrag des
Staatsbesuchs von Bundespräsident
Steinmeier unterzeichneten die
Arbeitsminister beider Länder eine
entsprechende Vereinbarung
Bundespräsident Steinmeier lobte die
Kooperation und wies auch auf das
deutsche Interesse an einer engeren
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit hin
beide Länder hatten bereits 2011 eine
strategische Partnerschaft
beschlossen bei der NATO werden sie
langsam nervö sagt unser NATO
Korrespondent in Brüssel das ist kein
gutes Zeichen für ein Militärbündnis das
gerne den Eindruck erweckt für alle
Eventualitäten bestens gewappnet zu sein
der natobeitritt von Schweden aber ist
zu einer schier unendlichen Geschichte
geworden dabei geht es
interessanterweise weniger um Schweden
selbst als um die Türkei und um Ungarn
die Probleme kommen also nicht von außen
sondern von innen aus der NATO selbst
und während der schwedische
Oberbefehlshaber seine Landsleute gerade
noch mal zusätzlich nervös machte mit
der Bemerkung sie sollten sich mental
darauf vorbereiten dass es Krieg geben
könnte in Schweden scheint in die Sache
jetzt Bewegung zu kommen Florian
Neuhann sehr geehrte Abgeordnete die
Nationalversammlung der Türkei eröffnet
ihre Sitzung so geschäftsmäßig beginnt
eine Debatte auf die der Westen seit
einer kleinen Ewigkeit wartet das
türkische Parlament berät am Abend über
den Beitritt zur NATO eine Saga mit
langer Geschichte mai 22 Finland und
Schweden bewerben sich gemeinsam um
Aufnahme in das Bündnis während es für
Finnland geschmeidig läuft Beitritt 11
Monate später wird die Sache für
Schweden zur Hängepartie der türkische
Präsident Erdogan lässt das Land zappeln
dabei geht es ihm offenbar um anderes
US-amerikanische F16 Kampfjets
monatelang wird gepokert wer sich zuerst
bewegt die USA mit den oder wie es jetzt
aussieht die Türkei mit ihrem
ja dieser Verhandlungsprozess war
geprägt von sehr geringem Vertrauen
zwischen den USA und der Türkei es
scheint dass es jetzt durchgeht aber was
uns in Schweden heute stärker besorgt
dass auf einmal Ungarn alles in die
Länge ziehen
will Auftritt viktorban aus Ungarn
bisher hatte der stets betont sein Land
werde nicht als letztes ja sagen zum
Beitritt Schwedens heute ist das
offenbar vergessen er habe den
schwedischen premier eingeladen schreibt
Orban um über den Beitritt Schwedens zu
verhandeln verhandeln wo längst alles
verhandelt ist der Tweet schreckt die
NATO auf was will Orban geht es gar
nicht um die NATO sondern wie bei seinen
letzten Blockaden womöglich um die
EU meistens ging es dabei ums Geld und
darum dass die EU die Gelder die wegen
recht
zurückgehalten werden freigibt man kann
es Druckmittel nennen man kann es aber
auch Erpressung
nennen die Autokraten in den Reihen der
NATO Erdogan und Orban rücksichtslos
auch gegenüber den eigenen Partnern ihr
Politikmodell beruht offenbar auf
Erpressung gepart mit einer auffälligen
Nähe zu ausgerechnet diesem Mann
Russlands präsidentladimir
putinis Verhalten ist doch dass er sich
emotional politisch verbunden fühlt mit
Autokraten wie Putin ansonsten hätte er
doch politisch so viel gewinnen können
hätte sein Land dem Beitritt Schwedens
schon 2022
zugestimmt 346 ja 287 Nein stimmen am
späten Abend steht die Mehrheit für
Schweden im türkischen Parlament das
ungarische tritt erst im Februar
überhaupt wieder zusammen
jetzt einmal rüber über den Atlantik New
Hampshire Elche schwarzbeären und knapp
1,4 Millionen Menschen ein schnuckeliger
neuenglandstaat um diese Zeit tief
verschneit New Hampshire hat es in der
Hand in New Hampshire entscheidet sich
heute die Frage aller Fragen für die
Republikaner in den USA heißt ihr
Kandidat für die Präsidentschaftswahl im
November Donald Trump was außer Trump
selbst fast alle Meinungsforscher an
nehmen oder hat seine einzige
verbliebene Konkurrentin Nicki Haley
noch eine Chance es wäre wohl ihre
letzte Claudia Bates ist in New
Hampshire dieser Bär war einst
verschwunden das war eine
zeitungsschlagzeile so ruhig ist es in
New Hampshire hier am Ende der Welt lebt
Kathleen Grindel Mac im Wahlsystem
eingetragen als parteilos als
unabhängige wie viele hier in New
Hampshire sie dürfen an den Vorwahlen
der
teilnehmen und moderate unabhängige wie
Kath Grindel sind Nick Hays große
Chance wonach schaut man bei Nicki Haley
sie ist jünger sie ist dynamischer sie
ist gemäßigter sie ist nicht so
spalterisch wie Trump und dynamischer
als
Biden unterwegs durch New Hampshire wo
Nick haly ihren härtesten Kampf führt
wenn Sie es hier nicht schafft ist es
Sie vorbei sie greift beiden und Trump
frontal an wegen ihres
Alters wir haben ein Land in Unordnung
und eine Welt in Flammen wir können
unseren Kindern nicht anbieten dass zwei
80jährige in die Präsidentschaft
gehen doch Trump liegt in den Umfragen
deutlich vor hay wir halten an einem
Waffenladen offensichtlich ein Fan des
Ex-Präsidenten Jonathan Stone stört sich
weder an den vielen Gerichtsverfahren
noch daran dass Trump Diktatoren
bewundert
er sieht wenigstens dass die Führer
dieser Länder sich um ihr eigenes Land
kümmern ob man mit Putin übereinstimmt
oder nicht er kümmert sich jedenfalls um
die Interessen Russlands und nicht die
Amerikas Amerika ist das einzige Land
das an der Wohlfahrt der Menschen hier
spart um das Geld anderen Ländern zu
geben und sein Favorit ist siegessicher
machthungrig scharen sich bereits seine
bisherigen Konkurrenten wieder um
ihn jeden Tag wird dieublikische Partei
jetzt geeinter ihr seht was
passiert kathen Grindel versteht Ihr
Land nicht mehr eines ist sicher auch
wenn Trump heute gewinnt ihre Stimme
bekommt er bei der Präsidentschaftswahl
im November
nicht er macht mir Angst wie er redet
macht mir Angst er wolle Diktator sein
nur für einen
Tag und die ganzen Prozesse wie soll
damit bringen dass diese Person unser
Land repräsentieren soll ich kann das
nicht ach und der Bär ein paar Jungs
hatten ihn kurzzeitig geklaut heute
Abend werden die Schlagzeilen
bedeutender sein einn in Großbuchstaben
wahrscheinlich
Trump ja erstes Ergebnis der Vorwahl
dann in der jetzt kommenden Nacht und
ausführliche Analyse morgen abend hier
bei uns
so jetzt geht's los bzw genauer gesagt
es geht los dass nichts mehr geht Heinz
die lockführergewerkschaft GDL hat ihren
sechstägigen Streik begonnen seit 18 Uhr
gilt der Ausstand für den Güterverkehr
in der Nacht ab 2 Uhr dann auch für den
Personenverkehr die Bahn hat einen
Notfahrplan veröffentlicht der Streik
ist bis kommenden Montag angesetzt und
der bislang längste in der Geschichte
der Gewerkschaft sie fordert vor allem
eine Absenkung der Wochenarbeit
ze die Bundesregierung arbeitet an einer
kraftwerkstrategie es geht dabei auch um
den Bau neuer Gaskraftwerke um
Energiesicherheit und auch um hohe
Kosten sieer me wie ist Deutschland
inzwischen bei der Gasversorgung
aufgestellt ja deutschland ist nach wie
vor stark abhängig von Gaslieferungen
aus dem Ausland die Kräfte haben sich
zwar verschoben denn man ist eben nicht
mehr so abhängig von russischem Gas
hinzugekommen sind aber besonders viele
LNG flüssig Lieferungen aus den USA
Norwegen oder von der Arabischen
Halbinsel aus diesen Regionen haben sich
die Importe in den vergangenen zwei
Jahren verdoppelt und auch das sei
riskant heißt es denn man denke hier nur
an Lieferengpässe die kommenden Wahlen
in den USA oder die unsicheren Seewege
im Roten Meer zu diesem Ergebnis kommt
der Fachrat
Energieunabhängigkeit er berät die
Bundesregierung wie Deutschland die
Transformation weg von fossiler
gasnutzung hin zu erneuerbaren Energien
gelingen kann lautfachrat könnte
Deutschland seine Abhängigkeit von
Erdgas um knapp 80% reduzieren und und
wie und wo genau soll der Gasverbrauch
gesenkt werden können also am meisten
verspricht sich der Fachrat von der
Umstellung der Wärmeversorgung in
Gebäuden und in der Industrie für
Privathaushalte werden unter anderem
Leasingmodelle für Wärmepumpen
vorgeschlagen doch diese Energiewende
hat eben auch ihren Preis und so werden
die Kosten für die Umstellung auf 526
Milliarden Euro bis ins Jahr 2045
geschätzt laut den Forschern muss sich
Deutschland nicht nur im Sinne des
Klimaschutzes sondern auch aus
sicherheitspolitischen Gründen
unabhängiger von Gasimporten machen und
das ganze möglichst schnell Sina meinitz
vielen Dank bei der
handballuropameisterschaft war für das
deutsche Team heute Spielpause vor der
für das Halbfinale entscheidenden Partie
gegen Kroatien Morgen und nach dem
klaren Sieg gestern gegen
Ungarn im Herzen eines Wintermärchens
der Blick in die Kabine nach dem Sieg
gegen Ungarn Erleichterung und Freude
sind bei der Mannschaft von Alfred
geslerson mit Händen zu greifen wir
haben es jetzt wieder in der eigenen
Hand wir müssen morgen gen Kroatien
gewinnen ja ist jetzt irgendwie nur noch
ein Schritt bis zum Halbfinale und wir
haben alle mega Bock und die Stimmungs
überragen die Fans in der Kölner Arena
in Ektase die Mannschaft auf der Platte
im Spielrausch das Angriffsspiel endlich
wieder Varianten Tempo und erfolgreich
das wird es morgen auch gegen Kroatien
brauchen die sind zwaschen ausgeschied
aber trotzdem mit Vorsicht zu genießen
wir sind gewarnt davor dass da ganz viel
Qualität kommt und die Jungs vor
allening nichts mehr zu verlieren haben
also jeder kann spielen und sich zeigen
ohne dass er irgendwie Angst vor Fehlern
haben muss deswegen ich glaube das wird
ein gefährliches Spiel hoffentlich mit
Happy End damit der halbfinaltraum
Wirklichkeit
wird es könnte eine glanzvolle Oscar
Nacht werden für Deutschland in diesem
Jahr bei aufregend vielen der nominiert
heute fiel jedenfalls das Wort Germany
zwei deutsche Regisseure Wim Wenders und
Ilker chattak gehen mit ihren Filmen ins
Rennen um den besten internationalen
Film der eine ist übrigens eine
Coproduktion des ZDF also auch wir hier
drücken noch mal ganz besonders die
Daumen und Sandra Hüller hat ihrer an
Auszeichnungen wirklich Reichen Karriere
heute eine weitere hinzuzufügen die
Oscar Nominierung als beste
Hauptdarstellerin in Anatomie eines
Falls wenn das kein Grund ist da noch
mal schnell reinzugucken waren sie
wütend auf ihren Mann nach dem
tragischen Unfall ihres Sohnes ja für
einige Tage er war für ihn
verantwortlich nur einige Tage ihr Sohn
hat sein Augenlicht fast völlig verloren
und sie waren nur einige Tage lang
wütend ich habe überhaupt keine Zeit für
mich verstehst du
das du beschwerst dich über dein Leben
dass du die ausgesucht hast du bist kein
Opfer gar keins klar du bist brutal ja
ich bin brutal folgt man ihrer Logik
waren alle Probleme von Samuel meine
[Musik]
Schuld sie ist die erste deutsche
Schauspielerin die mit so einer
Oscarnominierung geehrt wird seit fast
einem
Jahrhundert von einem anderen deutschen
der international Karriere gemacht hat
und Wirbel und Furore müssen wir uns
heute alle verabschieden Frank Farian
ist Tod angefangen als Koch im Saarland
über Rossbach bei Frankfurt in die ganze
Welt super Hits am flieband einer der
erfolgreichsten Musikproduzenten
überhaupt vermutlich der erfolgreichste
aus Deutschland Frank farien Schöpfer
des Sounds einer ganzen Generation wurde
82 Jahre alt der Nachruf jetzt von
Claudio
Armbruster eine Frage vorweg wer hat zu
seiner Musik noch nicht
getanzt Frank Farian
ohrwurmproduzent König der
[Musik]
Tanzflächen bony m sein Geniestreich
Musik die in die Hüfte schießt und im
Gehörgang kleben bleibt ob man will oder
nicht das sind Hits und das sind die
Zutaten erstens mal eine hervorragende
Melodie egal ob sie von mir ist jemand
anders man muss ihnen erm schöne
Harmonien vermitteln man muss ihnen gute
Interpretation vermitteln die Künstler
müssen guten Look haben frag du musst es
wissen was macht einen guten discohit
aus ich glaube das ist ganz einfach man
muss eine gute Melodie haben die
eigentlich sehr schwer ist zu die zu zu
komponieren die einfachen Sachen sind
die schwersten man muss dann auch einen
guten guten Beat haben für die für die
Diskothek müssen Atmosphäre haben dass
die Leute sagen boah das toucht mich und
dann können Sie auch in die in die
Platten Läden und wollen das Lied haben
und Sie hören sich dann Hund mal an bis
es nicht mehr bis aus den Ohren
rauskommt ganz zu Beginn seiner
musiklaufbahn trat er noch selbst auf
sein erster kleiner Hit
Rocky doch lieber überließ er die Bühne
den
anderen und zog alle Fäden im
Hintergrund
[Musik]
sein größter Erfolg nach bony m wurde
auch sein größter Skandal der Milli
Vanilli Schwindel was war das ein
Aufschrei damals 1990 als er Preis gab
dass die beiden gar nicht
singen ich hatte die zwei nicht mehr im
Griff ich konnte keine Entscheidung mehr
treffen sie haben nicht mehr auf mich
gehört und da war es
Zeit mein Projekt zu killen ich bin nach
New York geflogen
und einem Reporter gesagt die zwei Jungs
haben nie Ton gesungen und ich war
danach immens
erleichtert Frank Farian Verstand sein
musikalisches Handwerk und er verstand
es zu vergolden über 800 Millionen
verkaufte Tonträger nun hat er sich
verabschiedet was bleibt
[Musik]
sindwürmer
wenn sie jetzt keinen haben kein Ohrwurm
dann können wir leider auch nicht helfen
um 015 gibt's dann unser heute sch
Update mit n gö mir und von uns allen
noch den Kolleginnen und Kollegen hinter
den Kameras ein angenehmen Abend bis
morgen
[Musik]
wiedersehen
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter vom
Schnee der letzten Tage ist nicht mehr
viel übrig und jetzt kommt das nächste
mächtige Sturmtief das bringt dann
endgültig einen Schwall milder Luft und
eben auch starken Wind verbreitet gibt
es morgen Sturm oder schwere sturmböhen
zwischen 60 und 100 km pro Stunde auf
der See oder auch auf Bergen wie dem
Brocken oder dem Feldberg im Schwarzwald
sind es über 100 km pro Stunde bis hin
zur vollen Orkanstärke der Schwerpunkt
liegt vormittags an der Nordsee
nachmittags an der Ostsee während dann
von Südwesten der Wind wieder abnimmt
heute Nacht zieht erstmal der
warmfrontreen über der Mitte in den
Osten nach Mitternacht mit Annäherung
der Kaltfront nimmt der Wind aus
Nordwesten dann schon deutlich zu mit
ersten sturmböhnen und bringt die milde
Luft und das ergibt einen spannenden
Temperaturverlauf die Tiefstwerte der
Nacht zwischen 8 und 1° werden nämlich
alle samt heute Abend schon erreicht im
nachtverlauf wird es dann immer milder
bis zum Vormittag da gibt es Werte
zwischen neun und vorfrühlingshaften 14°
am Rhein und ab dem Nachmittag wird's
von Norden her dann schon wieder kühler
das liegt an der Kaltfront die
vormittags noch über der Mitte liegt mit
ihrem Regen nachmittags dann in Richtung
Alpen weiterzieht dann Lock jetzt in der
Mitte etwas auf im Nordosten gibt's den
ganzen Tag diese Schauertätigkeit
undterzu der Sturm informieren Sie sich
und achten Sie auf herabstürzende
Gegenstände am Donnerstag beruhigt sich
die Lage dann am Freitag kommt das
nächste Tief mit Regen und viel Wind und
der Samstag wird dann wieder ruhig
teilweise sogar mit viel Sonne es wird
nicht langweilig im Moment beim Wetter
tschüss